upgrade was directed by Leigh Whannell
and stars Logan Marshall green as gray a
man who undergoes a tragic accidents in
which he loses his wife and he can no
longer walk he's completely paralyzed
from the neck down and when a man comes
along with an experimental new thing
called stem gray agrees to let them put
that in his neck which allows him to
walk again but suddenly he has a voice
in his head that's controlling his every
move or he can choose to suppress it and
be in control of his own body but when
he wants stem to act and in this case
find the people who killed his wife stem
takes over his body and he becomes a
killing machine I heard a lot of buzz
about this movie out of various
festivals but I didn't watch a single
trailer because I wanted to go in blind
I liked Leigh Whannell a lot I followed
his career since saw what him and James
Wan did with the first saw is iconic in
regards to horror nowadays and working
with a low budget and I liked for the
most part has worked behind the camera
at insidious chapter three which I
thought was one of the better third
chapters and a horror franchise and so I
was very excited to see what he could do
with a film that is original yeah it's
sort of like a mix of Six Million Dollar
Man and some other things we've seen
before and it's most certainly a
familiar revenge story when it comes to
a man searching for the people who
killed his wife the actual confines of
the story itself we've seen this
millions of times but the fact that it's
a futuristic story set in a very dark
and dirty and grimy hard sci-fi world
really helps this film a lot and as soon
as we get that first action scene and we
realized the tone that Leigh Whannell is
going for this movie surprised the hell
out of me this is the type of movie that
John Carpenter might have made in the
1970s right around the time he was
making films like assault on precinct 13
it has a very dark grindhouse feel you
can tell Leigh Whannell was working
within the confines of a lower budget
but it never feels as if it cheapens the
film you don't get those overly
ambitious shots that seem like they
don't quite have the budget to pull it
off everything is presented on the
screen looks real enough and even though
I know for a fact the budget wasn't
something like Blade Runner 20 49 this
film still feels as if
could be in that universe the futuristic
aspects of this world and the special
effects never felt cheesy despite the
lower budget and this proves something
that I have been thinking about for a
really long time and it confirms it
directors who are used to working with
low budgets or no budgets coming up with
ideas from scratch like Leigh Whannell
and James Wan when they made the first
Saw movie they are able to create a lot
with very little because they're used to
not having anything
and since Leigh Whannell comes from that
background having a small budget and
this interesting concept he stretches it
to its limits and it never looks cheap
with every performance I see from Logan
Marshall Green ever since prometheus I
like it more and more every time if
you've never seen the invitation it's
really weird and definitely check that
one out sometime the ending is kind of
an but it's a strange movie and I think
it's unique and one that people should
see but he is fantastic here because he
understands the perfect balance between
tragedy humor and of course the action
sequences which you can tell he does a
lot of them himself
because once he lets stem take over his
arms start flailing around doing these
amazing things but his face is kind of
swiveling around looking at all of the
things he's doing in horror and it
creates a really great idea a really
funny idea because you have someone
who's out of control of his own body
once he permits it to do whatever stem
wants but he still has to look at the
things he's doing and the people that
he's fighting are also like you're
insane you're crazy what the fuck is
wrong with you and so it creates a lot
of great humor as a hard sci-fi action
film with a lot of good humor upgrade is
pretty much exactly the type of movie I
like to see there are problems that I
have with it are mostly surrounding the
characters gray as a character is very
well fleshed out you understand his
plight you see what is so terrible that
he goes through you see him for a while
as a paralyzed person trying to come to
terms with that and without a doubt this
character you care about him it's all
the other characters that suffer
especially the police officer I know
nothing about her she is just a cop the
villains in the film have no personality
they're just evil and we're supposed to
hate them because of something they did
this film has a hard time balancing
character and concept because the
concept is awesome
sure we've seen things like this before
but never quite through this lens
especially with the Scimitar fee of the
action scenes Leigh Whannell does some
pretty amazing stuff steadying the
camera with the movement of grey and it
creates some really awesome stuff but
the characters themselves surrounding
him were very weak which sometimes makes
the film a little boring when nothing
interesting is happening because you
realize you don't really care about
anybody except gray even his wife is
underdeveloped and of course you know if
you've seen the trailer and you've read
the synopsis you know that she's not in
the movie that much but that's such an
integral moment to this character that
there should have been a little more
meat I think there besides that upgrade
is a really fun movie a very low-budget
action film that feels like a grind
house 1970s film and I'm excited to see
it again I just wish that the characters
had a little more behind them I'm gonna
give up grade-a beat guys thank you so
much for watching I appreciate it to
look forward to more reviews very soon
as well as a preview of the podcasts
that I'm doing over on my patreon
account with my friend John Flickinger I
appreciate your support on patreon so
much I really do but I wanted to share
with you guys here on my youtube channel
every once in a while like 10 to 15
minutes from our podcast some of the
highlights cuz we talked about so much
on this podcast and I want to make sure
that you guys understand what we're
doing over there and have fun with it
and every once in a while I'll show you
guys like just a little preview of what
we're doing and I'll post that in a few
days guys thank you so much as always
for watching and if you like this you
can click right here and get stuck mine
eyes
[Music]